before the sky
out like a flame in the lights
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
check check check good evening good
evening good evening
good morning good afternoon
whatever it may be in your part of the
world
check check check one two one two
how's our volume are we reading nice and
clear not too loud
not too quiet
but just right
at least that's what I hope
I hope
dude like already Man Billy renewing
their membership Jason renewing their
membership that's a nine month for Jason
six months for Billy seven months for
tabby cat gaming eight months for Kieran
and one month for Bronwyn welcome in
Bronwyn thank you so much for becoming a
channel member here
welcome to house rack and tour my
friends
Jenna Lee Turner with the three months
let's see Alicia with the five months
Christy with the six months Nico with
the eight months
hold on did I miss one I don't think I
missed one
oh my goodness this song is this song is
counting down imagine if it actually
lined up
just an overload wait wait what
wait what
system overload
all right I want to test something real
quick here
oh I see yeah yeah yeah I think
okay it's like just off I need to move
it
don't worry we don't have to wait
another 10 minutes it's all good
we don't have to wait another 10 minutes
hold on did we just have Billy with the
10 gifted memberships
oh my goodness Billy thank you so much
dude Billy's like hold on retro you've
been streaming too much on Twitch we
gotta we we gotta show you some love
over here on YouTube
it has been super interesting man I'll
tell you to see like the difference in
streaming on Twitch streaming on YouTube
I blame Avalanche they threw our plan
off
I'm just kidding I mean they kind of did
but it's all good
it's all good we adjusted and made the
best of it welcome in guys welcome in
thank you all for being here on this
glorious evening at least it's evening
for me
on Tuesday April the 4th 2023 I'm retro
raconteur
and I'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell
WE Post weekly videos here at
youtube.com retro wrecking tour we also
stream weekly
both here and on Twitch and here and
back again and over there and over here
Billy thank you so much for the 10
gifted though and welcome to all those
new members of housewrecking tour guys
enjoy
not your ad reviewing because we're not
on Twitch enjoy your
special role in Discord enjoy the
channel emotes
you also get discounted merch as well if
you're interested in any of our merch
like this retro Recon tour hat right
here
I need to get a new one man and I'm
thinking about different colors
because I think right like Black's kind
of my go-to color black looks good on
anybody right you know so just like the
solid black
but I think I want to get I'm going to
experiment with some different colors
this time
oh how's everybody doing man
let's see and then I also saw I want to
make sure I didn't miss anybody I know
Billy gifted out the 10.
yeah for some reason it's like then it
shows some of the people who got gifted
separate
little no Ryan Kingsbury what's up Ryan
welcome in Nick Shaw Jacob Peterson I
can Nike Zodiac Zodiac I think I
remember you from uh twitch Jack Attack
Jared and then BK
oh also new dog what is up new dog
and then did I say Jacob did I say Jared
if I didn't welcome in guys thank you
for being here hope you all are having a
good night so far
oh does it look navy blue no it's not
navy blue I bet it might look bad
because of the uh like we've got some
blue light back here
so maybe that's like reflecting off of
it there's also a light up there
I did think about white Christie like a
white hat with the black lettering or
gray
I was looking in my closet at all my
hats
and I definitely have like a type of hat
almost all the hats that I have
they're like solid navy blue with with
some sort of lettering or logo on this
is the only hat that I have that's
different
the only one
oh a blue one
see if I did navy blue like everything
else though then it's just it just looks
like all my other ads
I should become a purple guy you think
so Cloud Roth
I did think about for our let's play
Channel I was like I should just have a
little fun with this Channel and make a
completely different
logo
or just take the one we have and make it
because when I first made that logo I
did it in like five or six different
colors and put them all side by side see
which one I like best and I do have a
purple variation
that might be fun for like a little
brand differentiation there just
slightly though you still know you're in
the right place
Elise first time to a live stream no way
welcome in glad you made it this always
happens so if I'm not caught up with the
chat yet don't worry we turn oh by the
way mods be prepared I turned off uh we
officially disabled
our slow mode
so right before Hogwarts Legacy launched
we were you know we were having some
pretty uh pretty packed streams so we
had to turn on slow mode to kind of help
control the chat a little bit slow mode
is officially off so go crazy everybody
chat all you want
no uh whether you're a member or not you
will not have any sort of uh cool down
Dylan welcome in Dylan oh man I must be
way behind if Dylan is just now saying
I'm just now getting the part where
Dylan says less than 10 minutes or wait
hold on Dylan's has to be delayed Dylan
I think you're I think you're behind
skip ahead
Christy is here as well welcome in
Christy
Oh Billy your retro guy gaming dude I
thought I recognized the logo the the
icon
so you changed up your name on us gotcha
Cloud Roth in the house what is up Cloud
Roth
good to see you my friend
Mrs raconteur in the house welcome in
welcome in
Stacy how's it going Jack Mia you gonna
have tacos tonight let's go
dude my wife and I we both been on
a taco just
I mean we've always loved Mexican food
but we went on a trip
last year
to
um
oh jeez
not Charleston I always want to say
Charleston not Savannah
oh my gosh
where do we go
she'll she'll let me know in the chat
but anyway wherever we went somewhere
uh they had this they had this really
that we went to this uh Mexican place
that had this just these
awesome tacos
I mean it's just like tacos it's such a
simple thing they were just perfection
just perfection I don't know what it was
like every all the ingredients were so
fresh the cheese the meat the lettuce
like like everything that was in there
was just so good and so since we've had
that we've just been like
we want tacos at least at least once a
week
at least once a week we've been having
tacos
Christy says white with the blue writing
okay okay so you mean like we don't have
anything with the full logo because I
wanted this to be I mean maybe we do
need something but I wanted this to be
like a standalone to where
even if somebody wasn't like a fan of
the channel you know they might still
see that hat and think oh that's a cool
hat like Retro Retro Gaming
I also thought about making one that
says retro and then some sort of uh like
gaming or something under it I don't
know
but yeah lots of ideas lots of ideas
Lynette yeah Lynette loves purple
no slow Mode's gone dude
slow mot's out the window
Chad can just go crazy now you guys have
free reign
it was Savannah okay I don't know why
for some reason I was thinking it wasn't
Savannah
Azalea welcome in Madame AZ on Twitch a
nice glad you found your way over here
to the channel as well
only 50 okay wait are you guys trying to
mess with me now
are you good
chat what is
I think you guys are just messing with
me now or some people are way behind now
Timothy ninja is saying only 15 minutes
Alicia stream start okay that's all I
needed to know you guys are trolling me
you're trolling me
but you know what just the double check
I have to check
let me just check here let me let me
look okay yeah yeah okay yeah I'm caught
up all right
can't trust you guys can't trust you
oh yeah yeah but YouTube does actually
have where you can like rewind you know
so some people may accidentally be at
the beginning and not realize it
foreign
think about it think about it you know
Billy finally got the story finished a
let's go uh one of no spoilers hey I get
it man
I get it yeah you gotta you got a nice
log of videos to go through now
I've I have several that I've posted to
the channel and we also have a big live
stream planned for tomorrow if you guys
aren't on Twitter
or in our Discord I'm trying to think
where all do we make this announcement
Twitter and Discord
we're gonna be on with expecto go
tomorrow
afternoon evening for Wizarding
Wednesday
alongside several other creators to
finally
talk about this we've talked about just
just me and you guys if you missed that
stream go back a week or two a whole we
had a four hour plus
deep dive
full breakdown of Hogwarts Legacy
and now I'm so I'm so ready to talk with
those folks about it though man it's
been driving me crazy honestly like I
try not to bother them
because I don't want them to feel like
I'm rushing them to finish
but deep down I'm like please hurry up
oh dude I get it though like you want to
take your time with the game we waited
so many years take your time I get it
but I just want to do a full-on spoiler
cast so I mean I I don't know how long
they all have but I'm I'm expecting it
to be a pretty lengthy one tomorrow
pretty lengthy
so yeah it's gonna be on James's Channel
expect to go so if you guys aren't
following over there that's where we'll
be we'll be live over there
of course you already know every
Wizarding Wednesday
every Wizarding Wednesday
hey AJ draws with the Super Chat thanks
so much AJ retro my friend glad to be up
late enough to catch a stream for once
looking forward to see you all on
tomorrow's discussion I'm so so excited
dude
so excited it's been kind of a weird
time for the fandom because we had to
shift into this
and it is still weird in some ways
because there's
I don't know like a fourth a fifth of
the fandom that hasn't even gotten to
play the game yet because of last gen
they're waiting for last gen
maybe it's more than that I don't know I
feel like
I feel like it's probably around there
but who knows and then everybody's kind
of going at their own pace so some
people like
like uh
Billy was just saying
and like you were just saying so many
people were just like I don't want to be
spoiled on anything so you had to go
dark for a while
oh but I'm so ready to talk about this
game so ready to talk in detail with
them about it
Professor Baxter in the house too what
is up Professor Baxter
okay I'm feeling this I'm feeling this
music tonight sometimes the music
it's Hit or Miss but yeah
you know what I'm feeling this so much I
gotta we gotta turn it up a little bit
guys
are you happy to be here Chad I'm happy
to be here I'm missing our animated
emotes from twitch though right now
the animated emotes YouTube you gotta
get on that
we need little animated emotes
because right now the the chat would
just be going crazy like with our
pipe emote
[Music]
oh dude it's almost over
I'm keeping it loud until it ends
Jenny in the house what is up Jenny
welcome in
[Music]
there you go Nico's got it
I didn't get a chance to watch that JP I
saw they were on talking about Zelda
though
you just finished the story today Genie
let's go then you got you guys can all
be here
you guys can all be here to enjoy
I will definitely play a magic Awakening
AJ yeah yeah yeah
all right turn it back down now
I will definitely play it and probably
stream it I want to figure out how easy
it is
[Music]
because it's it's a mobile game but yet
they say have heard you can also play it
on PC but you have to have some sort of
uh MooMoo player or something I think
it's called
and I tried to download it the other day
just to you know
just to see if it would
if that player would work and it I can't
get it working so I don't know what the
deal is with that but I'm gonna have to
look into it if not I guess I'll have to
set up my
my phone or something I don't know I
have to figure out how to capture my
phone on
because I know James does it but I think
he was
I don't know if he was using his Galaxy
or if he was doing it on PC yeah I
definitely want to play it and give it a
try may make some videos on it as well
zutara on your second playthrough let's
go
that's right Dr Sherbert I forgot about
the switch players too yes yes
Stacy welcome in Stacy Ryan how's it
going Ryan thank you for being here
Jedi Survivor does look like it'll be
awesome yeah
I'm playing through if you guys aren't
watching our live streams over on Twitch
and on our let's play Channel That's
where we've been posting all the all the
stuff
which we may I don't know man I've been
thinking about
this is what let's play Channel worth
the time like it's it's slow going on
the beginning but I think if we stick
with it over time I think it'll be for
the best choice to have a separate let's
play Channel but then some days I'm like
oh I wish I could post this on the main
Channel because I feel like some of you
guys are missing it
it's YouTube for you though it's how the
algorithm goes
but we do have a dedicated let's play
Channel actually let me see if I
I can't remember if I've set up the
command in here or not
oh no how are you welcome to group no we
haven't but it's retro reckon tour let's
plays you can just search for it and
find it Dustin in the House Dustin what
is up my friend Dustin with the five
gifted memberships
Dustin thank you for gifting out those
memberships let's see who got those
Stacy with a gifted Mia with a gifted
Tiffy land sassy sis and Krista marks
congratulations on your gifted
membership welcome to house track and
tour I'm not holding my hammer but
there's the hammer back there
welcome to house wrecking tour my
friends enjoy the emotes
dude the music is popping tonight
someday like this is all it's a it's a
player called pretzel rocks that's like
copyright free stuff
and some days man I'm just like oh I'm
not feeling this
I'm feeling maybe it's the night stream
vibe
I'm just I'm a night person dude I I
don't know what else to say
I just get pumped up when
Pumped Up Blue Moon welcome in
it is a party right oh I need to let's
get Hogwarts Legacy fired up though
people are gonna be yelling at me in the
replay Squad if we don't start soon
enough
so people go back and watch the replay
and then if I forget to put the chapters
in they're like what the heck dude the
thumbnail says you're playing the game
you talk for 20 minutes well sorry
this is our this is the community here
we have to have this chat interaction
it's what makes this all
so it makes the community what it is if
we didn't have this time if I was just
straight into gameplay
then you guys would be yelling at me
you don't even what you don't hear music
Baxter what
you don't you don't hear the music
hold on Baxter hold on dude
guys he said
guys guys
Baxter said he couldn't hear the music
he said he
could I need to like make these lights
start flashing
Professor Baxter sir
can you hear
the music now
because I can't hear myself anymore
[Music]
okay we're back down we're back down
we're back down we're back down
oh the replay squad's done they're out
now
they're they're just they're just gone
replay Squad just had their their
headphones absolutely exploded
Krista renewing their membership that's
a four-month streak for Krista
thank you so much Krista appreciate oh
you got the you got one of the gifteds
and it's four months let's go
Alicia with the five thing sn2 PO Box
should be there from April 14th to the
April uh
blah blah blah
hold on
you know what this moment calls for
requires a free hydrate right there okay
we're hydrated we're good we're locked
we're locked in
okay I promise it's just Coke Zero guys
that's it
that's all this is
all right Alicia the thing I send to
your P.O box should be there from April
14th through the 21st we get an unboxing
stream I mean depends on how many we get
I guess I've
so I know I know for sure you sent
something I know for sure Christy is or
has sent something
I think an unboxing stream would be fun
though yeah
hey Baxter I'm just I'm just having a
little fun I'm like wait you don't you
don't hear the music sir
you can hear me right that's the main
thing
that is the main thing
right You Gotta Have To You Gotta Have
the little
Community interaction time at the
beginning you have to
dude what is this pretzel rocks
has a new section called game stations
eight wait how many tracks are in this
thing
you've got Minecraft Call of Duty FIFA
fortnite League of Legends GTA okay the
thing that might
might overlap the most with Hogwarts
would probably be like League of Legends
well let's try this dude let's see what
we got here
okay okay
foreign
interesting blend right here
I feel like it could be a movie trailer
but then I'm like in
I mean goes to sushima at the same time
okay Bushido drums is the name of this
one
all right we'll leave it on here for a
bit see how this one goes
oh man
edit that part out of the stream where
we turn all where we turn the music way
up
yeah Christy it shouldn't take yours too
long to get here I don't think
Lauren from New York welcome in Lauren
Jack how's it going Jack
oh we're good new dog I'm just I'm just
happy to see all you guys
I'm just happy to see everyone Mr
renyard
welcome in crazy people of the internet
my birthday no my birthday is not coming
up I already had my birthday
my birthday was in February and I I
celebrated very
inconspicuously like away from nobody
knew no mods new no one knew
what's the consequence for ban word oh
we don't have any ban word on uh
on YouTube YouTube doesn't have all the
that's one thing YouTube really needs to
in terms of the live streaming
they gotta up their game is like the
whole Channel Point thing
and then I don't know if you guys if any
of you watched James's stream he's had
like the sound alerts on there so you
guys can play sound alerts on the Stream
so as far as I know YouTube doesn't have
any of that stuff
yeah on when we're streaming on Twitch
we have where people can redeem Channel
points depending on the game we're
playing I like to turn them off if I
haven't played the game before
yeah I think she won them back in did
she eat
it's gonna sit there
but um
I kind of like the idea of gifting
gifting Subs to people
that's that's what I'm leaning with
right now that's what we did the other
day when somebody got to got me to say
it
I've been doing pretty well with those
though been doing pretty well
oh Alicia's birthday is coming up
yeah Baxter we did we did we've named a
lot of them after
people from the Stream
today is Luna's birthday that's right
that is right
all right we got the console fired up
as much as we've been jamming out to the
music I think it's time for it to come
to an end
[Music]
I think it's time for the music to come
to an end
all right let's go to Hogwarts Legacy
man it's been a while
it's been a while
oh no
wait why are all these oh no don't tell
me they're all gonna pop up again
see we haven't streamed on YouTube in a
bit this is what happens you're a wizard
Harry oh my gosh they're all they're all
oh no
white refresh browser when scene becomes
active Okay refresh right now okay I
think we should be I think we should be
good now
I think we're good sorry about that guys
sorry about that
oh we playing some Hogwarts tonight
and now now I'm reminded of why
I stopped streaming
with OBS we're using OBS tonight
it has for some reason
it's not passing the audio through
to my headphones
hold on was Tim here wait where was Tim
oh there's Tim Timothy Timothy ninja oh
gotcha gotcha have a good one Tim I
thought you guys were talking about
Stargazer Tim for a second
yeah I uh
you guys can hear game audio right it is
not like I can't hear it's probably
really loud too
let me turn it down here
yeah for some reason I'm getting no game
audio at all let's go ahead and jump in
here and then we'll see we'll test it
out a little bit more
foreign
either okay so you guys just hear me too
that is so weird because it's showing
that it's going through
yeah I don't hear it at all though okay
hold on
well while we're doing that let's bring
back
we might as well bring back the other
music you know
I'm gonna troubleshoot this for a bit
yeah it
it started happening a few weeks ago
Dustin or probably a month or two ago
and then I had to start using
anytime I did a gameplay stream
I had to make sure I used stream Labs
OBS instead
and I thought I actually thought I fixed
it
because I have it set up now where I My
Stream Labs whenever I stream on that
I'm streaming with
twitch and whenever I'm just doing OBS
I'm on YouTube
Alicia with another Super Chat oh no I
already read that one uh AJ with the
Super Chat do all the sound effects with
my I should try it
oh man that'd be a we'd be in for a long
stream though
or a very short stream one of the two I
would probably just tap out very quickly
we could go back to our yeah we could
just let this music play though if we
have to
all right but first let me let me see if
I can't
figure it out here
all right so audio
[Music]
the crazy thing is is that it actually
shows it in OBS like the little meter
that moves back and forth
it shows it as playing
[Music]
oh wait a second here
hold on
hold on one moment
let me turn all that on
okay all of that is set now
okay so let me disable that
all right let me try this Monitor and
output
Stacy heading out too have a good one
Stacy thank you for stopping by oh man
lots of people here still haven't played
not wanting the spoilers
all right so now we need to go here and
deactivate
don't panic
let's bring you back
and
oh my gosh still no audio
I Know audio
OBS come on
wait you could hear the sound
okay wait how about now do you still
hear it now
okay I don't think you're trolling me
again but if because I I still cannot
hear it actually
I mean if you guys can hear it I can
make do with that I I can make do
without it that's fine it would sound
very quiet to me for the night but
oh dude that's too funny
oh it's very faint ninja dog says
here let me do this
Jenny you're bad at trolling you can
hear it
let's do uh
says loud and clear all right all right
I don't know why OBS would keep me from
being able to hear it
because I have it on to where I can
uh
nope
yeah it's on monitor I should I should
be hearing it
let me try one more thing and if that
doesn't work then
then I have one more idea after that
okay wait uh audio output that's what I
need to check here
the road makes you look old
I don't know I mean probably because
he's bald too
he has no hair hold on
let's get it get a nice view by the
window here he's got the scars on the
face
that guy's been through it Lord retro
Mort has been through it let me tell you
he has been through some stuff
no I've never tried xsplit never tried
it
here
okay let me open up the volume mixer
yeah correct output is set all right
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna have to
make do
I do have one other
because the
Oh I thought I heard it for a second
that was so weird
I'm gonna take my
[Music]
I'm gonna see if this will work
I'm gonna plug this into the PS uh five
controller oh that's too much to have it
on both
[Music]
there we go
all right now hopefully this just
doesn't stop you guys from hearing it
when I plug it in
right
ear let's see
oh it totally did
it totally did
Rob thank you for subscribing to the
channel you guys can't hear it now okay
oh that's too funny
all right
it was a good idea
[Music]
foreign
it was a good thought
hmm
[Music]
okay there's one more solution
there's one more solution if this
doesn't work then that really is it
it warms my heart to see I'm gonna plug
it into my monitor just this one
[Music]
and I also need to make a note to delete
OBS and not use it anymore
what's crazy is it's always worked like
OBS has always worked great for me I've
never had any issues
until there was an update they had an
update for it
and then after that ever since that
update it has just
my game audio is
chalked
oh yes this is gonna work
still going through to you guys
unfortunately it's getting worse
if there's any chance that the Relic
from slytherin's Spellbook can help her
I must find it Sebastian requesting your
help
meet me outside of feldcroft near the
kataku
bro
I said we were just gonna do side quests
tonight Sebastian
how's he gonna do that to me
[Music]
I can't believe that
warms my heart to see your interest in
herbology dare I say Blossom
imagine if I just kept going and never
like addressed addressed that
oh
[Music]
sorry I had to line the camera up
okay this is the point in the
[Music]
that also helps me know when to uh when
I go back and put in the chapter markers
later
go away Sebastian I know so on this
playthrough guys
if you haven't been catching our live
streams and catching our Let's Plays
this is our second playthrough of
Hogwarts Legacy
and we have been playing through as an
evil Slytherin learning all the
unforgivable curses
live streaming it
and also posting it on our let's play
Channel but
I haven't been really focusing on any
side quests that that playthrough is
really focused on the main story and
that's kind of it
so tonight for our regular YouTube
stream I thought we would just hang out
and I would just kind of go through
doing some side quests
and working on because I still even
though I don't need it for the trophy or
anything
I still want to go through and level up
my character somewhat
because
I'm playing on hard mode so you know to
beat the game and not
course
to beat it comfortably then we're gonna
need at least a few upgrades
alright so let's pull out our Quest page
here
and see what we've got so in the shadow
of the mind it's all gobbledygook we're
not going to do either of those we're
going to save those now stuff like this
Professor garlic oh wow so that one
where we learn imperio
I gotta save that for the let's play I
have to
have to but now these
like I don't mind doing those now follow
the butterfly spot removal
sweeping the competition
all we could do some broom trials yeah
yeah let's do some broom trials
play of the House of all that one's so
sad
let's do
yeah let's do some broom trials
have it going Christy thank you for
being here
can't wait to see what you've sent our
way cannot wait
I saw it was at you Rin Mr rinyart
earlier who said that streamlabs doesn't
work for you OBS works yeah
I quit using streamlabs years ago
and just started using exclusively OBS
and like I said I've never had
dude we gotta unlock some flu flames on
this playthrough my goodness
I I never had any any sort of issue but
for whatever reason
it just the audio won't come through to
the headset
even though you guys can hear it it's so
bizarre
so bizarre to me all right so let's just
kind of fly through you know what we
could just make this we could make this
whole stream just us flying through and
unlocking every flu flame because that
would be super entertaining would it not
let's mark that one first
I'm also noticing I feel like YouTube
live streams have way more of a delay
with you guys than
then twitch does
I mean there's always some delay on on
both of them no matter what
but I'm feeling like there's a little
bit of a more of a delay than usual here
like the current the last comment I'm
seeing right now is Mr rinard by Christy
as soon as the next person posts the
comment I'm gonna tell you guys exactly
when I see it
we can test this
very next comment after Mr renyart
now there it is Dylan boom
and I said it immediately when it popped
up
here we go
yeah AJ it's interesting like
there's some areas where YouTube's Far
and Away better and then some areas
where twitch is Far and Away better they
come after me they'll rest in ten Graves
and it never fails no matter which one I
stream on I'll have people pop in and
say
oh I love the this stream so much better
when you're on the other one
about a 10 second delay that's crazy
this time
oh and do we have a rebellion oh yeah
it's right over here
ginger root the bear keep I'm not gonna
this is just a casual playthrough I'm
not reading everything tonight
not reading them all like we normally do
we're just hanging out and vibing on
this playthrough
I will go ahead and sell some stuff
I have a delivery from Jay Pippin's
potions
sent a child to do his work first I
forgot we had this Quest oh waste
cutting corners and take an easy way out
did he have your brother for him as well
doesn't matter you could probably do it
better than he can anyway
just take the potions here are the
potions you requested you think it's so
simple you think Revelations have an
even bigger area of effect teacher's
customers
even after the upgrade
you'll not be getting a cannot out of me
because it also does uh when you're on
the Broom I feel like it does even more
I'm gonna say I'd rather not I'd rather
not but if you almost so be it I do
insist
there was like zero uh
zero Choice there whatsoever
all right what was it invisibility she
wanted me to do
nice to see you again
lay
wait
did we mess something up
what do you have for sale
what are we looking for what
it was invisibility right
and that's what I used wasn't it
drinking them all for fun and having to
make more
oh do you think I don't have enough
well do just fine
thank you I have no idea what just
happened there you guys
drink a few my first playthrough I
definitely only had to drink one
I'm thinking because I don't have
aren't you supposed to bring her four or
something
uh
yeah I'll save those two thank you for
stopping in I appreciate it
okay now let's check the quest
what is this one it's not sweeping the
competition
oh I have to give her three invisibility
potions
so we don't even have enough
hahaha
that's why it's not working
so I guess I did the same thing you did
Jenny I don't even have a
I think I had three total but then she
made me use one
which knocked me down to just two
way
did they not show up anywhere in your
inventory I guess you have to go to the
pull up the wheel
yeah now we only have one
or no we only had two
we had two drank one
and that took us down okay we'll we'll
just we just have to go make more
all right let's hit this one right here
and then we're gonna go do the flying
the next flying challenge
man that final broom upgrade makes such
a big difference
I know Azalea that's so annoying I guess
on my first playthrough I must have just
had enough
or or I didn't I didn't use them
I feel like invisibility potion is one
of the most
at least for me like I don't think I
ever even used one in the game
and I kind of don't understand the point
of it really when you have
oh it's a pleasant surprise when you
have the spell anyway the
disillusionment
all right now let's go over here
yeah I was doing some stuff earlier if
you guys didn't see our YouTube video
today man
no spoilers check it out any of you guys
can watch it it is uh of the dark arts
ballerina
I did a fun little challenge for myself
I this was a made-up challenge by me to
go through the whole
dark arts battle arena without using any
of the unforgivable curses and then it
turned into like how many times am I
gonna pass that door
no what do you want let me guess is it
an invisibility potion
what is it what's wrong
it's what all right stop just tell me
what you need
a Maxima sure right the world's not
round rocks what's he gonna give me come
on give me some invisibility oh he gave
me one invisibility yes we just need one
more then
all right perfect
but yeah that video I had so much fun
making and doing the edit for that video
so let me get let me know what you guys
think if you haven't seen it yet
to uh
about the different editing style it's
totally different from what I usually do
I know yeah Mr Vineyard I agree I agree
it just uh wait there's three
oh that's because that one is the one
that's like you have to go through the
mine
did you like it Ginny yeah I it's
totally different style from what we
normally do
I was like
what's crazy what blows my mind so far
and it's still early
is that people are not watching that
video as long
as they normally do on my other videos
I don't know so maybe it's just where
it's such a different style but like my
focus with that video is like I want to
see
with the editing I want to try and keep
it engaging and entertaining the whole
way through to where people feel
compelled to watch it all the way
through
and they're not
so I'm like well I guess I failed
but it's still early it's still early
like I said
but yeah I was just curious to you guys
the the dedicated
the dedicated live stream audience I was
curious to what you guys thought
because I will I'd love to do like more
challenges like that we could even do
this stuff like that on stream
he gave it for no reason Lauren no no he
he gives it to me because uh I kind of
skipped through the dialogue there I was
pressing triangle to skip through it
but there are a couple of NPCs that you
run into in the game where
they'll request a specific potion from
you
and he was requesting uh the Maxima
potion so then once I gave it to him
he gave me uh three different ones in
return
oh yeah so I don't think we can hit that
one from right here
The Shining bugs yeah yeah you can pick
those up they're uh I think it's
lacewing flies
they are used in some potions
oh yeah this is actually the area this
is where we're supposed to go
was it not right through here
I thought it was right through there
it's okay it's fine I'll do it later I
do want to get the broom one though
so let's go here to this Quest
and what was it
not a demanding delivery because we need
we need one more invisibility potion
I feel so slow
oh yeah that's what made me talk about
the video from today though yeah so I
was playing on my main my first account
my first playthrough and I have all the
upgrades of course 100 on that account
and my broom is maxed out now going to
this room it feels so slow
the second best Slytherin oh come on now
hello Imelda
so another trial
of course it's another trial and you'd
better be taking part
not bugs in the bushes the one that fly
in many swarms in different areas
oh they must just be uh what fireflies
or something then yeah if I'm thinking
about what you're talking about they're
just not very good no one sets records
by wishing I don't think they're
anything you can pick up or anything in
competition to stay on top of my game
are you going to try to beat my flying
record or not
course
I'm ready to fly finally a decent
challenge
my favorite broom Dylan it's not this
one it's it's the one that I'm using in
my
on my main playthrough
oh no I messed that up at the beginning
didn't I
now let's see if I'm just holding L2
down
oh yeah you could pretty much hold L2
through this whole thing excellent
because as long as you're hitting those
yellow
It's Gonna Keep replenishing it for you
[Music]
oh we're gonna miss a few
no
oh my goodness
imagine if we actually still get it
[Music]
I love the music when you're doing this
man it feels like it's right out of the
movie
they did such a good job with the music
sounding sounding familiar while at the
same time putting their own spin on it
[Music]
face all right a little over halfway
26 is her best time I actually think we
still got it
[Music]
I think we're still gonna be able to do
it
Mouse the keyboard makes this one really
hard
say the flying controls even on
controller they definitely take a little
bit of getting used to
because of how they set it up with the
Dual analog sticks
[Music]
to where One controls you on like the
vertical axis so like my right stick is
what
you go up and down like this
but then if you spin it left to right it
controls the camera it's a little weird
at first
alright so yeah we knocked that out even
running into the
whatever that was that big wooden thing
for a solid
10 seconds or so
all right and you've improved I must
admit [__] what destroyed your time I'm
Elda even running into something earn a
reputation for talent around here and
some people get put out about it sounds
like you're speaking from experience yes
well I am
anyway
I can't deny that
but you'll not have it I saw her I think
Lynette was talking about struggling
with fire with flying Violet pup you you
are um
you suck at flying Dylan loves the
flying challenges
do a poll
let's see who's been put out nah I don't
feel like talking to you anymore until
next time I have expected you to back
down
rest on your laurels I think we can go
talk to Alby now right you don't lose
your Nerf
to race this course again visit the
podium with the leaderboard yeah I'm not
gonna visit that right now but yeah
Dylan you were asking about my favorite
one my favorite one let me see if I have
it unlocked on this playthrough yet
can't remember the name of it that one
that one right there it's a successful
flight I should let Mr Wheats know that
is my favorite one but yeah on here I'm
doing the Ember Dash room instead
all right so we unlocked all right
that's good we're already so close to
this one
I'm gonna go ahead and get that before
we go talk to
our pal Alby
I'll be weeks
revelio page
can you get the revelio pages while
flying let's see
no I thought you might be able to
the jeweled brooch because you you can
actually pick up items that way
and you can even loot chest that way I
figured that out the hard way hey Mr
renyard gifting out five Subs to the
community
Mr rinard thank you so much for the
gifted Subs right there Violet Skyfall
Danielle Emily in soundtrack
in the house guys enjoy
your uh Channel membership there make
sure you think
Mr rinard for that gift you also have
access to the emotes now
you get a discount on merch if you're
interested
and a special Discord role
I thought you might be able to grab onto
those why can I not
pull in my broom right here
what has happened
no broom
search the loot bag there's another
wiggin weld
okay it's just level one but I'm
actually gonna not gonna worry about
opening any of those right now
wait who is this and what mission
fascinating truly oh I remember this one
hold on though
I need to unlock this flu Flame
night dancer is your favorite as well
and you get that one pretty early too
ninja dogs here on PS5 have a hard time
controlling as well yeah it's just like
it takes a little getting used to the
fact that
the right stick control the up and down
controls your character but the left and
right controls the camera
dude why can we not
it's not letting me get on my broom I'm
so confused
I think it's glitching out or something
why would we not be able to get on the
Broom here
that doesn't make any sense
I go ahead and go here and then I'm
Gonna Fly just a little bit Northwest
[Music]
the house with this sheet there's a
glitch that makes you fall through the
world
she can still fly the broom
oh it won't let you renew from mobile no
way
I I feel like I read Mr Mr renyard where
they are adding that
I want to say I I saw something from
YouTube a few
like a week or two ago
but it might it might be one of those
things that's just like slowly rolling
out or not fully available yet
hello world print hello world that's
something I want to talk a lot with
James and the crew about tomorrow when
we're on on live with expecto go
I want to talk about like the whole
morality AKA
the lack of choices
in that whole system
all right dude we're not doing so well
right now
[Music]
I can't do uh
what have you done
no
your poaching days are over
revelio and you know like the whole
morality thing I'm trying not to say too
much tonight because I want to talk I
want to really get into it tomorrow with
all of them
but when you when you have like no
morality system which is basically what
we have here
it almost makes like
alohomora the serious stories that they
try to tell in game like with Sebastian
for an example
it makes them have like almost less
weight like they don't feel as
meaningful as they could be because
well I mean if you guys haven't finished
Sebastian's storyline you make a big
choice at the end of that right
and I've had so many people say like I
went around the whole game you know
taking out all kinds of wizards how am I
gonna turn him in right
and it's like it's like a fair point you
know if that's how you've been playing
your character
then it makes that feel completely
different
all right so man this is hurting my ear
having these having this in under here I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to keep
this up maybe just one side
oh yeah that feels a lot better just
doing the one side
all right so let's see we need to go to
hogsmead and talk to Alby and then we
can upgrade the broom
he had again
Dylan I thought you beat it what you
didn't beat it yet
back from your latest flight using the
unforgivable curses isn't the only way
one must really choose all the mean
choices like not yeah we've been doing
that with this playthrough
been going all in
good news Mr weeks with your upgrade I
was able to set a new record at the
Irondale course I haven't even finished
all the Garb Stones
plastic potential how did you I think
the funniest one is with Lenora you can
just be like top speed and the handle
wobbles a bit when I solved it but I'm
not telling you yes
I'm not telling you how I solved it
thank you I owe you one if it means
another upgrade the pleasure's almost oh
you haven't beat me yet Dylan I can't
believe you to improve life oh my
goodness it's a joy to have a
collaborator like yourself
that's why you said that when I when you
uh dm'd me the other day
I was so confused when you were like not
listening
miss the weeks and I do make a good team
well we're not gonna be spoiling
anything tonight guys I should have told
them that at the beginning I didn't even
I mean I guess we kind of have a little
bit but
we're mainly just doing side stuff
tonight
all right I gotta figure out a better
way to get this
headphone on
okay that's not too bad
all right did you upgrade it for me or
do I need to buy something for today
[Music]
I think you have to come back right away
hope to see you again
oh definitely don't watch tomorrow Dylan
yeah yeah we're like tomorrow we're
going all in all in like if if somehow
you've managed not being spoiled to this
point then
that is that is actually incredible
might as well talk to Poppy since we're
here
to go in on this side
yeah because I I
we have uh we have a little Discord chat
and James said to list like three things
we wanted to make sure to talk about and
remind me several people have already
said Blake Sebastian's story a lot of
those poor dragons in the fighting
that's a big one that's a big wiring
Goblin
I think a collar is precisely what we
found at that poacher camp
I've never known poachers to use
anything like that before the dragon
that attacked my Carriage was wearing a
collar oh yeah it's gonna it's gonna be
a fun stream By Its Behavior we haven't
talked like I haven't talked with any of
them about about the story stuff
seemingly coming out of nowhere or even
about gameplay
of course I've been watching their
videos and still you know keeping
keeping up with what all of them are
doing but look at the dragon we set free
yeah being able to actually talk with
them and if we in person
you know we're not like all in the same
room but
you guys know what I mean that's a good
idea
shoot I forgotten I'm looking into it
right away there was something else that
I shouldn't have said to discuss with
you should have been like whatever I
didn't want to press it before
it seems I may have caused you more
trouble with Victor rickwood why is he
after you
Draco at this point I'm just like it's
all right
release the game he's not at the moment
that's it I'm not I'm not letting
why is this game not out as soon as I
can why
why is it releasing ever why is all the
world getting to play it except for like
UK and in a why why
so many people have played it I think
the game is in ready enough state it
should have been out by now
but to get to your question I I am
looking forward to finally giving it a
try I haven't played it I've watched a
little bit of uh other people playing it
but I have not personally played it at
all yet
all right so let's see what we want to
do next can I go ahead and do all of the
other
I should do that one just to get a rest
of momentum
oh wait
the invisibility potions
while we are here
let's go ahead and pick up one more
invisibility potion
Pippin sorry buddy we're gonna need to
buy a potion from you since we
accidentally used the other one you gave
us that we were supposed to be
delivering
there's always a but like every time
dude
like why why is what do they have
against us in the U.S and the UK
why is that game not out man like what
are they okay so for any of you who have
played have you played the beta Draco at
all like I'm curious how much is
actually changing
like if they actually changed a bunch of
stuff
during all this back and forth with
people
a wise decision thank you
oh I don't even have that recipe
I don't even know why I just bought that
but whatever
I hope to see you again farewell for now
never heard of it I've been thinking
about doing some videos on it Dr sherbet
to get people acquainted
what do you guys think would be a good
uh clickable title
this would be fun
we'll be Let's test with you guys what
would be a good thumbnail
and a good title for that video for a
video on like everything you need to
know about
the oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait can you guys tell I love
doing this stuff man
everything you need to know about the
next big Harry Potter video game oh what
do you think
for the title maybe for the title
but then what about the thumbnail see
the thumbnails is the biggest key that's
the first thing you see
because I made a Harry Potter magic
awakened video I don't know a while back
I think when it got
I think when it got delayed no not when
it got delayed when they said
oh my gosh when they said the launch was
imminent that's why I'm not excited at
Draco when they dude that game they
literally were like the launch is
imminent
it's releasing this year that was
that it never came out a game that so
many people are already playing
it's like how is it not ready what are
you doing is it or is it just like
translating what the heck
what are you doing over here buddy I I
think you're lost
okay wait I feel like we need to see
this through now we need to see where
this where is this dude going
excuse me
dude if you like transformed into a
human I would lose my mind like if it
was an animagus
you're just gonna keep standing here
are you gonna
wait is he going back he's
he's going back
he got up here he's like welp
whelp that's not gonna work
oh my gosh look at this one Rebellion
what is up with these goats man
all right
a Wizard's guide to wizard Oh you mean
magic awaken ice
okay you guys make it sound like I'm
I'm not gonna be that clickbaity
unless I legit spent a thousand hours
doing it
did he fall off no way no way no way no
way
and did I just like completely ignore it
happening
oh wait revelio oh there he is
dude this goat is Magic over here man he
climbed back up somehow
we should transform one of them you guys
there you go
all right I saw a little treasure over
here
I saw a little treasure
I know it said sheep but
dude that's a goat man
wait
are golden sheep are they different
wait a second chat
wait a second
what is happening
all right uh let's see did we get
everything we wanted to here
oh no I'm supposed to yeah yeah yeah you
can I interact with you now it seems to
have worked hmm yeah you saw me like an
hour ago I was right here if the demand
for potions is as high as you say if you
considered being easier to work with
perhaps combining your recipes and
skills
I just shop handed to him
Dylan no no news on a new game plus man
and I hope so
if he fails on his own gotta think
they're just like all hands on deck
right now for
uh last gen
very well so they're probably no idea I
mean you could tell these first few
weeks they're like okay we're gonna get
out the big updates for patching the big
bugs and everything
but now I feel like I'm actually I'm
actually kind of like are we gonna get
anymore patches today
cause I'm sitting here without my
hundred percent trophy like please
please we need some more patches
we need some more patches please oh that
was an upgrade
it's okay it's fine it's fine we'll be
good don't worry thank you for stopping
in I appreciate it Moon spark welcome in
oh I didn't see who got you the gifted I
did not see we've had several already
tonight though gifting memberships
several gifted memberships already
tonight
AJ draws have a good sleep my friend
always good chatting with you AJ
appreciate the donations the super chats
yeah for sure Dylan I think so too and I
and then
and maybe even before they announce any
like big uh
like you were saying like like uh
A New Game Plus or something
which the game I I'll say this the game
definitely neat and we'll probably talk
about this on tomorrow's stream too
the game definitely needs a new game
plus it definitely needs more to do yet
for the end game yet at the same time
ah this is such a tough one man like I
don't feel like people should let it
negatively
affect their impression of the game
because so many of these people
complaining about like you know in-game
stuff they're like yeah I spent 60 70
80s 80 hours with the game and now
there's nothing to do
it's like
okay you paid what 70 bucks for the game
like how okay how
how like game this is this was never
billed as a live service game it was
never
build as a massively multiplayer online
role-playing game is never billed as
that it was a single player action RPG
if you get 60 70 80 hours out of a game
like that's I feel like that's more than
your money's worth personally personally
I do
now all that being said do I wish there
was more to do absolutely
and that's why I keep talking about I
think they have such a unique
opportunity to do something
do something different with this game
that you don't see a lot of single
player games do and that's not not turn
it into a live service not turn it into
some big multiplayer thing
wait hold on am I gonna be able to get
this one
we should yeah
but to turn it into this thing man that
like you
you keep releasing these updates
and you sort of turn this into a living
like a like a living breathing world
where this game updates where you have
New Missions now of course
there's only so long you can do that
before you have have to start charging
people right they can't just do that
free forever the reason it works with
live service games like fortnite and
Apex and all the other ones you know is
they have monetization tied to skins and
things like that and I don't think
anybody wants to see that for Hogwarts
Legacy and I don't think they would do
that anyway
but the way you could monetize is with
like these little DLC expansions like
these little upgrades along the way for
more story content
more spells
more Cosmetics but they're like all in
you know
all part of a larger thing
I became a Harry Potter hog where it's
uh Harry Potter magic awaken Dev
oh my gosh you guys want me to straight
up lie
I'm not doing that
oh did you get an email letting you know
who the gift came from
all the clickbait titles and Mr Beast
Boys
I just played Harry Potter magic
awakened for 1 000 hours
and you guys aren't gonna believe what
happened to me at our 950.
boom we're in
all right what do we want to do next
Let's see we completed that one
I'm kind of just enjoying this like
flying around Vibe we got going right
now let's just
let's just go around and try to unlock
let's go get some more flu flames
because then we can teleport to anywhere
anywhere in the world
you guys seeing this
dude what are we inside right now
what
what are we Inside Man
I feel like there's part of my
on the Broom but I'm inside
wait is this is this the glitch somebody
was talking about earlier
you said wait you said fall through the
world but you're still on the Broom is
this it is this the one
oh my gosh man we're still on the Broom
all right hopefully imagine if this was
game breaking imagine hopefully we can
just do
like fast travel to another one
but I think because we were still on the
Broom it made our character wait we're
not on the boat now pitiful based caught
in my truck
excuse me sir
oh no no oh I'm trying to keep him
Airborne for 10 seconds
oh wait this is actually tough hold on
okay
oh my goodness okay he doesn't stay up
long at all with good Olivia delaying
the inevitable
oh my goodness how do you do it what
other spell do I need
Leviosa doesn't come off cool down quick
enough
I guess you could do I mean flopindo
kind of makes him hover a little bit
doesn't it
oh if you go back to the same one it
fixes it too
gotcha
that's the first time I
ever seen that 80 plus hours on a
playthrough
never had that happen
ing oh learn you fall underneath the
world
they say you can't get into any house
you're not a part of that way
oh wow
get all these in a little ah
you got flinched oh that was good
good
oh my gosh look at this dude this spider
going crazy
dude that spider just absolutely wrecked
that Goblin
oh my goodness
defeat an enemy with a Chinese chomping
cabbage
nah
Lord retro Mort would not use such a
thing
enjoy yourself do ya
do we have here
a lovage bouquet
this Memorial serves as a grim reminder
of the power of magical beasts
years ago a young witch was killed here
by a Grappler and she awaited her true
love that love now returns to this spot
to remember her and leave a bouquet of
lovage her favorite plant
I did not even know that was a plan
is that how you say it lubbage
where's the flamethrower hey that's uh
incendio and confringo
all right let's go let's keep going here
okay I think we have all of the
blue flames over here
these are the hardest ones to get
because
let's go to this spot right here
oh is that in Wizards unite as well
nice little throwback huh
okay yeah it's this one right here I'm
gonna mark
all of these three are a little bit
tricky to get to
because I think you have to go
you know what it might be is it up here
ah an ingredient collected for potions
nice
in Wizards Unite
oh yeah this is the one right here where
I learned that you can collect loot
while flying
because I kept thinking you're gonna
have to like raise like stand on
something there and then raise it up
but no you can just fly hover right next
to it
and search it
and then let's see we already got that
Landing platform
okay wait hold on let's let's let's zoom
in right here so we can really
all right how do we get you
should we go to that treasure Vault
first
you think we'd remember how to do this
hey have a good one Dylan appreciate you
stopping by my friend
thank you
okay is this it you guys do you guys
remember how do we get
I want to get to this one right here and
I can't remember if we're supposed to go
through oh actually you know what I
think it's over here
Mark like
I don't know for sure but I think that's
where you get in there
oh I don't know if you can accio that
kind of bag Draco that's a great
question I know you can acco the other
style of loot bag with that one I'm not
sure
is it right here
yes here it is here it is here it is
guys this is how you get there
okay now
let's go ahead and Mark you
hopefully we can get all three of them
right here
[Music]
oh my goodness
oh you messed up my incendio bro how are
you gonna do that to me
what's up
heal
there it goes
yeah you're right I remember that now
Lauren that is a quest
you are right about that
what did you hit me with dude
I will make you pray
somebody else
and I think it's yeah it's right around
here
[Music]
gosh The Point Blank Range crucio
oh trying to fly over it
Alicia that is what we did on the very
first stream of this game
it was when it was uh we were playing
the Monday before launch so we got we
got word from WB that we were allowed to
stream it early that day
and I didn't want to spoil anybody I was
like what can we do not to spoil people
and I just went around kind of doing
what we're doing right now of trying to
uh
unlock flu flames and see how big the
map was stuff like that
and so we ran around until until I
figured out how to get in here
he actually had one of the the devs for
the game was in in our chat
and we were asking like can we is it
possible
and they said it's possible you can go
anywhere
oh dude do we have a what do they call
them Infamous foe in here as well which
I feel like have we not unlocked let's
see
oh we got three Talent points available
let's go dude we definitely need to
unlock the one for
the transformation spell
wait where is that one at is that under
spells it is let's go yes
foreign
for sure
dark arts
oh we have to unlock AK okay yeah we've
we've gotten everything we can in the
dark arts right now
see I'm a little hesitant on all of
these because
I want to make sure I save plenty to do
all the dark arts
on this playthrough
all right we got an Infamous foe coming
up
ozbert the odd right there
I didn't even see the pop-up for that
one
[Applause]
oh no better heal
I've been fighting since before dude
that guy is not playing
you should have known you would lose
come on man
yeah we that's right Draco we did
we timed it too we started all the way
at the bottom
and flew to the top
I think it was like nine minutes in
something
doing here this Patrol is worthless I'm
just going straight for awkward up here
it's probably a mistake but
see how much damage
no way it took him out
oh
[Music]
I'm still trying to get used to having
a different set of spells Lucio on here
okay you know what sir
oh my gosh
dude it makes such a big difference when
you have your gear upgraded
yeah how do we want we want to hit that
guy with ancient mask
that is crazy to me
yeah hard I mean it's taking us more
time on these guys
level 24.
all right let's keep going through here
the stylish top hat
yeah it was pretty fun Jenny to fly
through and just see exactly how big the
map is and see that was like it was
early so we didn't have any of the broom
upgrades either
all right so we just unlocked that one
and then there's gonna be one more
where is that that one's like down here
somewhere isn't it
see where are you at it's so weird how
you can't look directly underneath you
when you're flying
mysterious and a bit unsettling all
right unlock that one
okay now let's go ahead and fly up here
might as well get all these balloons
foreign
oh see I'm so not used to it running out
that quick
the last one right here
got it okay
see now that we're down here
you unlock all these additional well now
you can get to all of these
all these other flu flame locations
how far am I now I'm used to or with
with the unforgivable curses so we just
the Imperial Quest just opened up when
we started this stream but I'm saving it
for twitch
and uh
since we've been doing the full
playthrough over there
and then for our let's play channel so
tonight we're just going through and
doing a lot of the side quests to level
up our character
first
here
goodness this closure execution
wait he is just like
dude that guy's health is ridiculously
strong
let's use Ancient magic
hit him with a crucio follow up by a
spring
wrong button
[Applause]
did I not just unlock the upgrade that's
supposed to turn them into
hold on
I thought I got the one that turns them
into an explosive object
oh I didn't do it what
what
hey we definitely did that time I guess
it didn't hold it long enough earlier
foreign
there we go
dancing roll up yikes let me free let me
free let me free
look at this guy man
he is confused
he is so confused
all right hit you with a crucio take you
out of this battle for a bit
hold on sir
excuse me sir
excuse me
dude it is I don't know how I missed all
these glitches on my first playthrough
Azalea have a good night thank you for
being here
ah yep I know how that goes gotta get
them up and ready for school
he is totally glitched out just
completely gone
all right poacher Ranger
oh wait I was gonna say it is easy not
gonna vanish away
okay
I still hear some other ones chattering
around me
but it doesn't matter because all we're
worried about right now let's see what
else is there to unlock here we do have
a couple of uh
Infamous foe right here
Iona Morgan
wait is this
does it always show up on the map like
that where it gives you their little
description
I don't ever remember seeing that
after graduating Hogwarts Iona Morgan
was turned out by her emotionally
abusive family
looking to her old friends from the
school she found a new family and Home
in the poacher pack
because see like for this one it doesn't
say that
doesn't have anything
huh
I don't ever remember seeing that
something
maybe it's like when you discover them
or something come here
oh dude they took me out quick right
there
you don't remember that either Dr
sherbet yeah that that is so strange
I'm gonna see if it's still there
see if it oh it is see we still just
have this
oh
not enough space to call my mouse
how about now
oh dude we got hit on the Broom
oh no
okay they're just sitting there juggling
me
all right there's so many enemies around
that took me out
okay I gotta quit playing around
we gotta get serious here man
we gotta get serious
ly
I thought we'd just be coasting through
this but nah not so much
because we haven't really upgraded our
gear much either some nice flowers
death count one no it's more than that
we
've died a couple times all right you
know what you're you're just really
annoying me from up there
let me know
all right got rid of you you were being
a big pain I just want you to know that
a really big pain over there how can you
even see me
what there's another one up there now
all right ancient Magic on you
why is there another one up there
yeah we're playing on hard
these dude these guys are
this is like the most
what is happening with this area
JG welcome in
okay even for Hard Mode
I have never felt it this difficult oh
you know why you know why guys we are
we are way under leveled for this up
here let's see what's our current level
we're level 24. let's see what they are
time to see someone a lesson
see I totally forget we're not just
supposed to go anywhere
oh dude
let's see what level are you guys
oh they're over here aren't they
and we still have that little skull
there
oh they're level 24.
okay
two hits
oh my gosh
Jake what is up dude Jake with the Super
Chat
Jake thank you my friend you have some
really good news well let's hear it my
man let's hear it can't believe you're
still waiting on the game on the switch
Draco that's what I was thinking too but
it shows I'm 24.
I'm actually like kind of excited now
we have a little bit of a challenge here
I'm not used to this in a while with
this game
you hold still
experience
all right
we didn't take any hits we're good
all right we're still full health
I don't want to use any like potions or
anything either okay why does another
one showing up over there
all right
they are relentless
why can't why is my skull not hitting
huh
you know what okay this guy right here
oh my goodness
go stealth no way no way no stealth
no stealth
I was trying to do accio yeah like the
first one I pulled down but then two
seconds later another one shows up there
all right so we've got
okay that one right there I'm gonna take
you out first
and we're gonna use this for a little
bit of cover
s
okay now I'm not even gonna leave this
spot because I know they send another
one there
where did you come from
all right all right all right good good
good got both of you taken out
now hopefully another one doesn't just
randomly decide to show up look at these
spells man I'm having to roll constantly
they're hitting me like through that
little grate right there
you shy
oh there's Iona Morgan okay we took her
down to half with the ancients
serious sir
all right we need crucio dude
that going to
okay to basically take him out of the
battle
reduction
that was one shot
was that not one shot
that was one shot was it not chat
Jake with another Super Chat
uh you know tennis right I got second
place in regionals in the Dallas Fort
Worth area going to stay only been
playing for three years dude that is
awesome man let's go
let's go congratulations dude everybody
round of applause for our pal Jake here
that is awesome man
good luck to you good luck
it was 81 degrees felt like a hundred oh
man
I was half Health what I thought I used
a wigging weld like right before that
person hit me
I'm gonna have to start doing like this
because this is really hurting my ear
it is hurting my ear we're having audio
issues tonight chats when we're having
to have this weird setup
hey this was so unexpected but I'm here
for it man I'm here for it
I just can't get over the aggressiveness
they're just so aggressive
oh come on accio mist
holy
tear off
all right got rid of you now there's
gonna be another one show up up there
yep there you are
and I need I need to be using more
parrying too with stupefy
okay see I don't think I need to roll up
can they actually yeah
they cannot
how are you hitting me out here
oh and you were just in the back epic
spot up there look at her dude all right
you know what just uh
they're hitting me through that I think
is the problem
bring down
okay see I just used
[Music]
okay definitely was not half Health but
I did see my wigging world did not fully
heal me
it only healed me to about 75 okay so I
do need to make that final wig and weld
yes Jenny yes I just I saw it I thought
of it right before I read your comment
because I have the one for
I have like the first one
or I had the second one but I didn't do
the first one
all right let's just go ahead and get
that
you know what let's
uh
I feel like I want to do glacias
oh I don't have enough freaking free go
right now I should have done confringo
first
the lady in red yes Iona right right
right
and I'm here's what here's what else I'm
confused about guys so are there
actually two enemies here are there two
Infamous foes or is she the infamous foe
right there um that's what I'm a little
unclear about
come on why does that not hit
that was
not even in here yet I'm not even in
here yet
let me out
you know what I'm just going straight in
dude look at this
see how fast we die
oh wait this actually might be better
I know where are you there's Iona
dude I still have health why am I
falling down like this
this is insane
wait that's Iona isn't it
I have
I'm kind of being overly cautious with
my heels right now
did we get Iona
oh yeah right here
[Applause]
let's coach your executioner has so much
health man
no no no we cannot die now
oh of course you pull off the shield
no
you imagine dude
this guy has a ridiculous amount of hell
now you've gone too far
not revelio
value is not what we need right now
holy wow that was insane
one more person though hold on
gosh that was insane
all righty
this dude's like wait
what happened to everybody
I have not been challenged like that in
this game in a while revelio
that was fun though I liked it
you're learning so much
oh yeah that lady in red for sure I I
think we got her when we cast the
the transformation spell
hitting her with that transformation
oh wait there's a mission here too no
way
oh it's a map
oh yeah I remember this one
huh
a location marked on the map isn't far
from here
henrietta's map
oh man I do not remember where it is
though in the game
oh wait is it the seahorse one
oh it is it is it is
this one right here kind of at the
bottom of the seahorse we're looking for
a little cave
all right so the the area shaped like
the seahorse is right
right down here at the bottom of this so
kind of like right in this area
oh man look at this so we're gonna have
thank you Draco yeah that was a little
rough going there for a bit but we we
settled down we settled down I think it
was best just to get in there like that
like we did at the end there
I'll be battling some spiders out here
I was playing too passive I guess but
trying to like wait around outside
probably
they just kept hitting me with uh
okay wait are there any that way oh I
better go get this one first
okay so let's just assume it starts with
that one then we hit the other one
all right now this one
see is this the last one or is there one
more kind of underneath there nope
that's it
that was it
it's been ages since I found anything
and I also see
more balloons up ahead oh more balloons
there and more balloons here
what is that noise
is that a troll somewhere
that's gotta be a troll right
oh and we got a little landing spot
right here let's go
let's go see all this stuff we're
earning XP for so it's
it's definitely worth doing it for our
even though we're not really worried
about getting 100 on this playthrough
still worth doing all this
what level they are in this area oh yeah
good point we should we should take a
peek
let's see when we find an enemy I'll
land
oh right here here we go
I'll check out I'm still still showing
up his 24. I heard something
what if that's glitched or something
because I thought they were supposed to
be hiring stupid
it's shameful what you've done to
helpless beasts
it's shameful what you've done
it's like 30 to 40 at the coast
Hey Jake appreciate you stopping by you
sounds like you definitely need your
rest man
appreciate the super chats my friend and
good luck
that's awesome news from Jake
no uh Jester I I think it definitely has
potential
I definitely think it has potential
I do feel like most I mean to your point
most of the reaction from fans is like
no I don't want them to remake the
original
and I'm just like really
because I would love it
I don't think it's too soon
and listen like what people have to
understand at least from my perspective
is like I'm
I'm such a die-hard fan when the first
when the movies came out I was just like
so
hyper critical of them and like thought
they could be so much better
and one of the big critiques I mean one
and two
I feel like for the amount of book
material you know that's a good size
book to make a movie out of but then
like once you get to three
three they started they cut some pretty
big stuff four oh my gosh like once you
get to four they had to cut so many
things
so many things to make it work for a
movie
and then of course five six and then
seven they had to make into two movies
to to fit it but then you tell me you're
gonna like devote a full season to each
book I would I would love to see that
I would love to see it
hello
that I don't care I just need to and
welcome to the almost awesome stuff to
you is that right
I've only been running it a short time
myself but my father ran it for many
years yeah I know right Draco it's crazy
that's been that long
date yeah they cut a ton of stuff
gesture they cut a ton
congratulations on your many years of
success to you and your father right
Lauren that's the big rumor right now
the big rumors that HBO Max is doing is
side by side once again trying to get
now a word about your health and safety
I can't remember where they said I think
they're trying to get this about JK talk
Wizards even though JK and WB and all
took everybody to approve everything
supplies that will help say okay we're
going forward
please have a look and do come back
original seven books thank you in each
season
best of luck to you and your father I
appreciate your words
may I see your wares
please have a look
okay we can solve that thank you kindly
for your business
I'll sell that one too
yeah that's what that's what the rumor
is Jester yeah that it would be one
season for each book which is
although man how would that work
now they could do it you could just you
could change the length of each season
as I was about to say some are so much
longer than the others
what a true Lauren true hey at least
with this we already know how it ends
and most people are satisfied with the
ending other than you know a couple
people being upset with the epilogue
and by a couple I mean a significant
significant portion of the fandom
didn't I should say just didn't love the
epilogue it's not like it was anything
just awful
I think it's mostly the names and stuff
that people were like
[Music]
thank you
oh and we got another Landing platform
right here perfect
yeah I think they were just
there are so many things they could
given the proper time and
attention to detail like imagine
obviously Avalanche makes video games
you know but imagine somebody giving
like
the Harry Potter treatment that app like
the level of detail and love and care
that Avalanche showed
for a video game set in this world
imagine if somebody did that for a TV
show
because I will I will forever say you
know the movies
they they did a great job at bringing
bringing Harry Potter to the mainstream
they did they're good
enjoyable movies
heck
that was crazy how they were it was like
red yellow and purple side by side by
side
but they were not great adaptations of
the books
except for the first two the first two I
mean we're like pretty darn close
okay what are we doing just kind of
flying out here like crazy
and I still like I still love and
appreciate them for what they did like I
still enjoy watching them but I have to
like separate them
somewhat from the books in my mind you
know
all right let's go ahead and get this
flu flame right here I can't believe
Albie hasn't contacted me yet
maybe I already do I already have
I was wanting to try and knock out all
of the broom upgrades
oh I have to go back to Pippin now on
that one
I guess I have to progress some other
things first
yeah JG I know they they did that for so
many people yeah
so many people
oh wait what do you mean by the new new
Canon versus the old cannon
oh my gosh dude look at that dug bog he
is not having it
uh this one I want to make sure we get
while we're down here
Goblet of Fire your best book but worst
movie
I enjoyed Goblet of Fire a lot yeah at
the book
my favorite still Deathly Hallows but
man it like trying to rank those books
is so hard for me because I love them
all so much
I don't know that I can do it I really
don't like
it's really tough to rank them for me
it's really tough to rank the movies too
it's more for the movies for me it's
more about like scenes and
moments like I feel like there are
certain scenes and moments that the
movie's absolutely nail
and again I don't want it to make it
sound like I'm I'm hating on the movies
I like I enjoyed them I enjoyed all of
them but I still had
as like a die-hard fan you know the fans
the most die-hard fans are usually the
ones that are most critical sometime
because they you know
you love it the most you want to see it
being
as good as it possibly can
the whole uh did you put your name into
the Goblet of Fire
yeah that was egregious just so bad
which I still say man like Michael
gambin he's
he is not my Dumbledore these rocks have
seen better days
I'm pretty sure it's on record like he
wouldn't even he wouldn't even read the
books
like come on dude you're playing one of
the most important roles
in the whole series you're not going to
read the books now he had his moments
like there were times when he
but for me he was just like
he was missing that that like twinkle in
his eye
that Richard Harris had now Richard
Harris was a lot older so like if he had
if he had lived through all the movies
I would have everybody says he wouldn't
have been able to do it at his age but
I'm like man I would love to have seen
him had a chance to try
but if he was like 10 years younger oh
10 years younger Richard Harris would
have just absolutely nailed it
because you know Dumbledore has to start
getting a lot more active in
well really from like
five five six and seven yeah he has to
be pretty active
they moved better that's about right
yeah yeah yeah
oh you never see anybody else down here
Lauren
well I'm glad we are here yeah we so
I've already beaten it on our on our
main our first playthrough we've 100 at
everything but tonight for this stream I
didn't really want to do a bunch of
spoilers so we're kind of just
going through our side quests and then
when we
stream this again on Twitch we'll we'll
start knocking out story stuff again
I think my biggest thing is um
humor to worry about I just like I
wasn't a fan of David Heyman I think is
or no David Yates David Yates when he
took over
I just wasn't as big of a fan of his
of his like position
and he's I mean don't get me wrong man
he's done some great things for the
friend and clearly cares
a lot about the franchise he's done a
lot of great work for the Harry Potter
franchise but like I just
is his like whole like overall vision
for everything I just didn't just didn't
fit with where
how I thought it should be
there were there were a couple of like
key things that they just they missed
and I'm like oh you cannot like you
cannot miss that
like that that is that is crucial to the
heart of
to the heart of it
so many little like little things like
that that just added up
oh Dr sherbet had to head out
oh wait how do we get in here
oh I think we might have to go in for
this one
I think we might have to travel on foot
whoa I don't remember this flu Flame
having to burn something down like that
to get to it
this probably isn't even it
all right I'm just gonna keep following
it
looks like it Loops back around
wait a minute what
where are we supposed to go
to get to that flu flame okay that I
don't need to go that way that takes you
into the
okay wait we can fly here
but then once we hit that road
oh yeah there's a little path
you should lead us up then
oh my goodness Rossi welcome in it's
been a while
hey it's all good dude I understand
you had first on many a video many a
video life happens though dude all good
oh yeah Elder Ring's great JG one of my
favorite games although I
without watching a vati video video to
explain it to me I can't say that I
fully understand everything that was
happening and going on
[Music]
um
go ahead do it hit me
oh now nobody wants to hit me
as soon as I stop to wait for it they're
like nasty
[Music]
that was a nice incendio
get up
that was a very nice incendio indeed
Rebellion
should be a chest
right behind me
okay yeah I think we have to go this way
not not this way I'm just grabbing these
[Music]
oh yeah winky versus Bill all that the
Marauders in movie three
and like I like I like the third movie
quite a bit actually but
I don't know
to blame
yeah I feel like the first
first two movies are pretty accurate
movie three
is when things started to they started
to take a little bit more Liberty yet at
the same time I love like I loved
Alfonso Quran
I love like his his vision for the world
I I really liked it
and I enjoyed that movie too but there
were there were still even in that one
some decisions that
you could start to see ah okay
they're taking a little bit more Liberty
now
spew oh man well spew I mean kind of
ended up not being a big deal in the
books to be fair
to be totally fair
okay wait what am I oh I don't need to
go in that little
okay turn around
[Music]
follow the path not that way right
yes this way okay
we're back on the right way
Naruto never watched it
never watched that one or read anything
wait can I not get on the Broom right
here oh no
okay I literally just tried that two
steps over and you wouldn't let me climb
it
but right there we're good for some
reason
hey Christy gifted out a membership
Christy thank you so much for the gifted
membership
let's see who got that Draven got the
gifted membership
congrats Draven oh is this a quest does
this not lead me up to the
is it not gonna take me to this flu
flame though
I think we can still get to the flu
Flame
yeah yeah here it is
here it is
[Music]
you can't imagine how inconvenient
travel was before I invented flu powder
oh I was gonna be so disappointed if you
didn't say at that time big nature
was gonna be so disappointed
yeah see yeah we'll be like that's
that's one of those little things it's
like oh wait where'd all where'd all the
school robes go
they're gone
little little things like that it's like
when you say just one of them it sounds
like oh you're being super Petty but
then they kind of they start to add up
all right so now let's get out of here I
don't think we can uh
yeah we can't fly from here so we gotta
just oh dude that was kind of creepy
yeah I'm just gonna ancient magic the
way that dark Mongrel was looking at me
I did not like the look of that
can't believe the video oh yeah yeah
it's our biggest video ever Rossi by far
by far
the magical first look at Hogwarts
Legacy
yep
man I'll never forget that whole
experience like what went into making
that video and
the trip getting to go and play the game
early
lightning in a bottle for sure
I don't know if I'll ever have a video
do that again maybe one day
maybe one day
all right can we fly again
I forgot about that we'll be I forgot
all about that
I forgot about that
that is too funny
Tom the bar man yeah Igor from
Frankenstein
oh dude
all right
now we should just be able to fly around
from here
when Hogwarts Legacy 2 comes out I don't
know man we have to have to do it all
over again I was just I was thinking
about that Rossi like looking at that
video
because obviously you know as as a
YouTuber you want to look at your videos
that are doing well and be like okay how
can I
how can I have more videos like this and
that one
it's just such an outlier in terms of
everything that went into it like
covering the game for two and a half two
and a half years or whatever it was
before it even came out
all the people that we met on that trip
and
I plant like like looking at the
thumbnail for that video it looks like
such a simple thumbnail
I plan that thumbnail for weeks probably
months probably a month in advance I
plan that thumbnail
and changed it a couple times too
talked with other creators about the
thumbnail about the title
and usually with a lot of videos I will
uh I'll go back and be like okay maybe I
can change up this title or thumbnail
but with that one it just like
from the get-go man it just
it just hit on a different note
on a completely different note
yeah I was talking with James expect to
go I remember we were sitting in the
hotel lobby
the Night Before Our gameplay session we
were sitting in the hotel lobby and now
we were just like talking about
content creation and stuff
and I showed him my thumbnail it was it
was a slightly different version of the
thumbnail I ended up using
but I showed him the thumbnail because I
was debating I was like okay
we knew we were going to get to play the
game and get to see some stuff that
people had never seen before
so there was this tough decision to be
made of like
do I show a shot
of something completely new that no one
has ever seen because we were able to
capture footage
so it's like we're gonna have some stuff
that people have never seen before of
this game
and so there was a while where I really
thought about using that for the
thumbnail
and then ultimately decided and I knew
it had to be something
the text
I knew I had to have the logo in there
because I found through all the Hogwarts
Legacy videos that I make
it tends to perform a little bit better
when you have the logo whatever reason
don't know why so I I knew I was like
okay I'm gonna have a logo in there
and in the text I wanted to be something
really simple like just a few words like
I played it
I just played Hogwarts Legacy
I played the game something like that
you know
and then the image the image was the
tricky part I was like okay but what
what image do we pair with it
and so ultimately I decided to go with
something that was already very very
familiar to people
so it was like combining the familiar
which was the image of the the Dark Art
the uh
oh geez what's it called deluxe edition
cover
but was that image obviously zoomed at a
certain level and
you know saturation sharpness all that
adjusted a little bit
and then so it was like combining
something that was very familiar an
image that people recognized but then
with text that you like
you almost couldn't believe at first
right
like those are the best videos when you
when it when it seems like what there's
no way this is real this is clickbait
and then you click on it and it's
actually legit
so it was just like okay I'm just gonna
have that shot
I'm gonna have the Hogwarts Legacy logo
and then I'm just gonna say I played it
then you get the dot dot dot in there
for like that Curiosity Factor right
because it's like you played it
and then what right like what what like
how much did you play
what did you see what did you think
so that was sort of the decision making
behind the
behind the making of that thumbnail
okay let me see here
oh absolutely Arya yeah my kids and I
and my wife were gonna watch it
probably this week I hope so yeah I
can't wait I think it looks so fun
wait hold on did I Mark something
what did I just Mark that one's that far
away
let's do this one first
that was a little bit closer
no it's not a dragon it's like a little
uh
oh what do you call these things
it's just like an enchanted
where did it go
it's like an enchanted tree
but it oh here it is here it is here it
is yeah yeah
and if you get too close they'll like
breathe leaves
oh come on do the leaf do the leaf
you're not gonna do it
maybe if I cast a spell on you
there it is
there the leaves
just one of those little like nice touch
things that they added
oh yeah Cloud Rock there is a huge
science to thumbnails
huge
it really is like it can make or break
it you could have
the best video that has ever been made
on YouTube I mean the best video that's
ever been made
and if you do not have a good thumbnail
it will not get seen
so it's really
it's like you have to make sure you make
a good video of course
but you also have to have a really good
thumbnail title is important too but not
nearly as important as the thumbnail
thumbnail is like the first thing people
see
hopefully
then you have to it's like you're
competing against so many I mean just
think about every day you go to your
YouTube homepage how many videos you see
that pop up
it's like you have to have something
there that stands out that gets
attention
oh man so many balloons
hey have a good one Alicia
thank you for being here tonight
always good to chat with you
oh there's a drag There's an actual
Dragon too in the game
spoilers
I mean you guys should know that from
the all the trailers and stuff
all right let's grab this
your guide page while we're here
Rebellion
where are you
there it is
[Music]
so yeah Cloud Roth I know James does
this and a lot of creators do this where
you have
at least two thumbnails prepared for
every video
and then if it doesn't perform how
you're hoping you swap it out and you
can like look in real time and see does
it go up does it go down like today
today's video
and sometimes people catch it like I
notice it a lot more where I make so
many YouTube videos when I see people
change them like oh you changed that
thumbnail you changed it
but I've changed today's a couple of
times
so the video that went up today I have a
version with my face and a version
without my face
and the version
I started the version without my face
then I switch it to with
and it went up a little bit
then I switched it back and it went back
down so I'm like okay it must be this
one must be better with the face
but then I switched it back and it's
going back down again so I'm like oh
maybe they're both bad I don't know
oh this is a wide stretch of water here
to fly over
I think we'll get more packs with mounts
similar to the dark arts pack
yeah it would definitely be cool if in
if in a DLC they added more more
creatures oh I'm gonna enjoy this
gunning
I love the the
on one side you have her saying I'm
gonna enjoy this and then ignatia how
nice to see you my young friend
and then we have one more way down here
might as well go ahead and knock all
these out since we're already down here
you know
and what do we get up to we're up to
level 24 almost to 25 I think
oh
it's a pleasant
Merlin trial
all right South clagmark Coast hey what
do you have here buddy everything all
right far from it I wandered into a room
and was attacked by spiders oh if you've
got some wig and well did I miss one I'm
sure that would put me right
Wigan weld all right Bud spiders do tend
to appear even though we're playing as
Lord retro Mort I have enough time I'm
only doing it because I know he's gonna
give us some other things in real life
oh don't worry
yes yes I shall stay away from they keep
it I have to remind myself wait we're
supposed to be doing our evil play
through on this Fighters it's supposed
to be an evil playthrough
oh see thank you
please accept this token of my
appreciation appreciated Hawksworth all
right Lauren you said I missed one let's
see which one are we missing here
okay
we got that one now we got that one we
got these two
which one are you seeing
oh right there maybe that one is tucked
in there good
tucked in there just right underneath
all right we could go ahead and fast
travel here
yeah there's a lot more they could do
with room of requirement as well
which what I can't figure out about room
of requirement is
I feel like they need something to
I don't even know how you would do this
but like to incentivize it a bit more
like even even animal crossing right
which is the most chill
game imaginable like
you're just vibing on your Island you
know
but even Animal Crossing has that rating
system for wear each week
they will come in and rates like your
your decoration skills and all that and
then you have your the star rating
system for your Island like how good
everything looks so it's like I feel
like they need something
I know it's not meant to be one of those
things that you're
super you know it's it's not like you're
not meant to be super um I don't know
what's the word like
gamified it's not meant to be like this
big all these rewards to it oh look at
that beautiful sunrise you guys
Roger there you go
Mr rignard with the three months uh nice
let's go dude
appreciate the three months man
is Animal Crossing good
well JG we got a lot of videos on animal
crossing here on our Channel depends on
what kind of games you like honestly
um it is a very different type of game
it's it's way more of kind of a Vibes
chill out
not many objectives virtually no
difficulty I mean there's a few things
that require like some
level of skill like phishing and such
but even that doesn't doesn't require a
lot
I would even say it's less uh it's it's
in the mold of something like stardew
Valley but it's it's even less it's it's
even less of a game than star do in
terms of like tasks and challenges and
all that sort of thing
I shouldn't say task there's a lot of
tasks to do for sure
it was a great game for 2020 though
great game for 2020 when everybody was
locked in pandemic uh it was it was just
such a great chill out
and relax kind of game
oh dude look at that one right there it
was nestled in no way
all right let's go get this one
stop playing when your children became
hoarders no upset when you dug up at
Soul stuff yeah I mean there was a good
like six months where my son and I just
we just loved playing it so much he had
his own house I had mine you know
separate save files
we had such a good time with that game
but it is very different like it's it's
not a game that
it's not a game I feel like the only
time I played it for like a significant
amount of time like multiple hours in a
row is when I was like updating our
Island like terraforming and
redecorating the island all that stuff
but it's a game where you like you check
in for a few hours hour two a day do
your sort of daily stuff and then you're
done
all right let's take a look at the map
here
a little yeah I could see some Minecraft
comparison certainly much less so on
like
the building side of things but yeah
oh no dude some of these flu Flames they
literally just hide like right up next
to
other pois
you've been playing it since the game
Roger I played the very first one on the
GameCube I did yes
my sister loved that game and my she was
my girlfriend at the time now my wife
she got into it as well
so yeah it's it's you a lot of times
with Animal Crossing people who aren't
traditionally Gamers will enjoy it a lot
too
all the decorating and like stuff you
can do with patterns wait did I
completely Miss oh wow we just flew
right
flew right underneath all those
the crazy thing now is with New Horizons
like if you were a new player now
oh my gosh there's so much content
so much content in that game
you still have your GameCube nice I
still have a Wii not a GameCube though
you definitely heard that wait what did
you hear wrong
and by the way welcome in Brittany good
to see you
all right guys did we I think we've
gotten
all of the Southern flu flames
wait where did the flu Flames show up I
know they show up somewhere
collection field guy Merlin Hot Spot
balloon any platforms
do the flu Flames not as they're nowhere
you can see if you've checked them all
off
I feel like I'm probably yeah I knew I
was probably missing some up here
oh oh
no yeah you definitely heard that wrong
or I could have misspoke it's late
that's also possible
that is also possible
but yeah guys I think we're gonna call
it there man I hope you all have uh
enjoyed the stream tonight a little bit
of a different different vibe we're
still kind of experimenting with this
Tuesday night live stream to see what we
want to do with it last night we or last
night last week we did just like sort of
a gaming news show we watched some
trailers
tonight we were just doing a more chill
stream of playing through a game and
then some some nights we just sit and do
like chat q a for a while
so I'd love to hear your thoughts man if
you guys have any thoughts on what you
uh
like to see like what sort of vibe and
atmosphere you enjoy the most we also
stream over on Twitch as well
where we're more
how would I how would I phrase it more
like gameplay Centric gameplay focused
no wubby
not like that
you love the chill Vibe like chill just
like playing through games
see the thing that I'm realizing that
makes it hard when you're playing
through a game
for the first time like we're playing
Star Wars over on Twitch
and like I'm like invested in the story
you know so I'm wanting to
to read everything and and but then I
also I don't want to like neglect chat
either and see I'm so used to all of our
live streams leading up to the release
of Hogwarts Legacy like it was so heavy
on
interacting with you guys like the whole
time like I'm responding to just about
every comment
and so when I'm doing more gameplay
streams where I'm like where I really
have to be focused and invested in the
game it takes away from some of that a
little bit
ah
as long as zillion as long as I can beat
it I'm gonna try to beat it
which
we're gonna be out of town this week
Thursday and Friday
but I might be able to play it some this
and I'm trying to only stream that one
too but I think I'm over halfway I do
think I'm over halfway so we should be
fine I need to really hit the hit the
grind hard with with streaming next week
to try and make sure I knock that game
out but we also might be streaming
tomorrow too I don't know I don't know
the plan yet I got to figure out what
the
what the schedule is with the family
tomorrow see if we're gonna have any
time where I can do a quick
a quick stream oh I remember what it is
tomorrow if we did do a stream tomorrow
it would be during the day I need it I
need a break between we've got a big
stream planned tomorrow if you guys
weren't here at the beginning uh James
AKA expecto go and several other
Hogwarts Legacy creators including
myself we're gonna be on
James's Channel tomorrow Wizarding
Wednesday
at 5 30 Eastern Time
and we're just gonna be it's like full
Hogwarts Legacy spoiler cast like we're
gonna be talking about all our thoughts
from the game
all of it all of it all of it is fair
game
so I'm
really looking forward to that really
looking forward to talking with them
so yeah if I do a stream it have to be
early
oh yeah I love the Uncharted games we'll
be love Uncharted
yeah actually when I played uh I don't
know if you've watched our let's play
episodes of Star Wars we're posting
those on our dedicated let's play
Channel now we've got a separate channel
for just Let's Plays like much much less
edited on those videos
I compared it to Uncharted which I
didn't know like there were so
for such a high profile game there were
so many things I didn't know about
Jedi uh Fallen order
and that was one of those things that it
was like dude this game is really
inspired by Uncharted
a lot of I should say a lot of Uncharted
inspiration that you can see in that
game
and yeah I uh I loved all the Uncharted
games though yeah they're great
great games
Professor Weasley oh you should
you should do it
all right
let me make sure I'm not forgetting
anything
I don't think I'm forgetting anything I
think that's it
guys thank you all so much for being
here tonight I've enjoyed the stream
hope you all have enjoyed it as well
if you haven't seen today's video make
sure you check out that video leave a
like on it let me know what you think
because it's a completely different
editing style be honest like give me
your honest feedback leave a comment let
me know retro love this style retro not
feeling this new style I like this I
didn't like that
let me know how you feel because uh
we're gonna keep going with this with
this YouTube stuff for sure but we're
trying to figure out sort of what videos
we're gonna like where are we gonna
settle in right I wanna I wanna find a
good Groove for the types of videos you
guys enjoy me putting out now that
Hogwarts Legacy is out right we can't
we gotta make videos other than Hogwarts
Legacy to keep it to keep it rolling and
keep it going so always appreciate the
feedback if you guys aren't in the
Discord we do have a Discord as well
exclamation point Discord in the chat
uh for some reason a lot of people want
to send me things and they've been
begging me for a P.O box we finally got
the PO box set up
exclamation point mail in the chat right
now if you're interested in that
but yeah as always
thank you all so much for watching guys
and I'll talk to you again
soon later